JAY Z DO.
THAT'S THE ANGLE.
HERE DIRECT, VICTOR DAVID
HANSON.
HOWARD KURTZ, HOST OF "MEDIA
BUZZ."
AUSTAN GOOLSBEE, FORMER ECONOMIC
ADVISOR TO PRESIDENT OBAMA.
VICTOR, WHY DOES PRESIDENT OBAMA
FEEL HE ALWAYS HAS TO COME OUT
AND TRY TO REBRAND HIS
PRESIDENCY.
IT SEEMS REALLY INSECURE.
THEY ALWAYS CLAIM DONALD TRUMP
IS INSECURE.
SEEMS LIKE IT'S VERY INSECURE TO
SAY I AM THE ONE WHO GOT THE OIL
STUFF GOING WHEN THE FACTS
FRANKLY ARE NOT THERE.
IN COMPARING THE TWO ECONOMIC
RECORDS, AS YOU SEE ANDREW
PUZDER DID YESTERDAY.
>> THE PROGRESSIVE MIND-SET SEES
POLITICS AS A 360-DEGREE, 24/7
OPERATION OR JOB SO THE LAST DAY
IN OFFICE IS THE FIRST DAY OF
ANOTHER PROGRESSIVE CAREER.
WE SAW THAT WITH JIMMY CARTER.
HE ALWAYS HAD THE COMMENT AND
EDITORIALIZE AND TRAVEL WHEN
REAGAN WAS PRESIDENT.
DURING THE BUSH PRESIDENCY,
AL GORE AND BILL CLINTON WERE
QUITE ACTIVE IN CRITICISM.
OBAMA IS DOING THE SAME THING.
FOR THEM, IT'S A NONSTOP
ACTIVITY.
THEY NEED A RANCH.
HE SHOULD GO TO HAWAII AND BUY A
FARM AND FOCUS ON NETFLIX.
REAGAN WENT TO THE RANCH.
W WENT TO THE RANCH AND LET HIS
PREDECESSOR BEING.
IT'S KIND OF -- NOT AN IRONY
THAT WE HAVE AN ANTITHETICAL
PRESIDENCY BACK-TO-BACK.
PROGRESSIVE BEEN STRICTLY
CONSERVATIVE.
WE NEED TO LET HISTORY
ADJUDICATE.
YOU BROUGHT UP FACTS, BUT THE
PRIOR ADMINISTRATION PROGNOSTIC
GATED THAT YOU NEED A MAGIC WAND
TO CARRY OFF WHAT TRUMP PROMISED
AND PAUL KRUGMAN SAID THE STOCK
MARKET WAS GOING TO TANK AND
BARACK OBAMA SAID YOU CAN DRILL
YOUR WAY OUT OF OIL SHORTAGES.
LARRY SUMMERS SAID 3% GDP.
>> Laura: IT WAS ALL A FANTASY
FANTASY.
NEVER GOING TO HAPPEN.
NEVER GOING TO DO --
>> GOING TO DO ALL THESE THINGS.
LET HISTORY DECIDE.
WE ARE ONLY 18 MONTHS INTO THE
ADMINISTRATION.
OBAMA SHOULD STOP RELITIGATING
THE PAST.
>> Laura: LET IT PLAY OUT.
WE WILL SEE.
MAYBE ALL OF THIS WILL GO AWAY.
HOPE IT DOESN'T.
I WANT TO FOCUS ON THE MEDIA
ASPECT, IT REALLY IS QUITE
SOMETHING BECAUSE A LOT OF
THINGS THEY ACCUSE
PRESIDENT TRUMP OF,
THIN-SKINNED, INSECURE,
NARCISSIST, BOASTING.
THE FINGERS ALWAYS POINTED BACK
AT YOU.
IT SEEMS LIKE WHEN YOU WATCH
OBAMA, YEAH, HE'S COOL.
BACK IN THE CHAIR.
HE'S FUN.
BUT IT SEEMS LIKE A LOT OF THAT
GOING ON HERE.
>> BARACK OBAMA GOT THE MOST
GUSHING PRESS SINCE
GEORGE WASHINGTON AND CLEARLY HE
MISSES IT AND MISSES THE
SPOTLIGHT.
HE HAS TO GIVE A REST OF HIS
GOLDEN OLDIE ABOUT FOX NEWS.
THAT RECORD IS SO SCRATCHED UP.
HE IGNORES THE FACT THERE ARE
THESE LIBERAL MEDIA OUTLETS THAT
MAKE TRUMP BASHING A 24/7
BUSINESS MODEL.
ALL EX-PRESIDENTS TALK UP WHAT
THEY THINK IS GOOD ABOUT THEIR
RECORD BUT A LOT OF IT IS THE
INDIRECT SHOTS AT DONALD TRUMP.
HE DOESN'T MENTION TRUMP'S NAME
BUT WE ALL KNOW WHEN HE TALKS
ABOUT NOBODY NEAR ME WAS
INDICTED, HE'S TALKING PAUL
MANAFORT, MIKE FLYNN.
I THINK HE'S TRYING TO MAKE
HIMSELF LOOK BETTER.
>> Laura: WHY IS OFFENDING
HALF THE POPULATION A GOOD
STRATEGY FOR EXPANDING HIS
INFLUENCE INTO 2020?
IT'S THE SAME THING THEY ALWAYS
DO.
IT'S WHAT HILLARY DID WITH THE
DEPLORABLES.
HE GOT AWAY WITH IT WITH THE
TURK
LINDER THERE ARE NOT MANY OBAMAS
LINDER THERE ARE NOT MANY OBAMA.
FOX, TALK RADIO, THEY HAVE
UNIVERSITIES, MOST OF THE
CHURCHES, MOST MEDIA OUTLETS
STILL, MOST ALL NEWSPAPERS.
IT'S STILL NOT GOOD ENOUGH.
THAT'S WHAT IS STUNNING TO ME.
>> BARACK OBAMA'S VIEW OF THE
WORLD IS THAT HE STILL CAN'T
BELIEVE DONALD TRUMP WON THE
ELECTION.
>> Laura: HE CAN'T BELIEVE ALL
PEOPLE DON'T LOVE HIM WHICH IS
WHAT THEY ACCUSE TRUMP OF.
TRUMP GETS MAD A FEW SLIGHT HIM,
IF YOU CRITICIZE HIM SLIGHTLY,
TRUMP REMINDS YOU OF IT BUT
THAT'S WHAT OBAMA DOES.
>> PROBABLY FEELING SLIGHTLY
EMBOLDENED THAT THE DEMOCRATS
TOOK THE HOUSE.
>> Laura: WE WILL SEE.
THIS IS WHAT THE PRESIDENT SAID,
SPEAKING OF NO INDICTMENTS.
HE MADE THIS COMMENT.
>> NOT ONLY DID I NOT GET
INDICTED, NOBODY IN MY
ADMINISTRATION GOT INDICTED
WHICH...
BY THE WAY WAS THE ONLY
ADMINISTRATION IN MODERN HISTORY
THAT THAT CAN BE SAID ABOUT.
IN FACT, NOBODY CAME CLOSE TO
BEING INDICTED.
PARTLY BECAUSE THE PEOPLE WHO
JOINED US WERE THERE FOR THE
RIGHT REASONS.
>> Laura: OH, REALLY?
LET'S GO THROUGH THE LIST.
SHORT OF INDICTMENTS.
FAST AND FURIOUS, IRS SCANDAL,
SOLYNDRA, TAXPAYER MONEY,
BENGHAZI, DEAD U.S. AMBASSADOR.
SUSAN RICE SAID IT WAS A TAPE
THAT CAUSED THE DEATH.
THE VA SCANDAL, A DISASTER.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF VETERANS
DENIED CARE.
OF COURSE WE HAD THE OPM HACKED
BY THE CHINESE WHICH WAS A
NIGHTMARE.
WE COULD GO ON AND ON AND ON.
SO YEAH, NO ONE WAS INDICTED.
IT'S MORE RELATED TO THE FACT
THAT WE HAD LORETTA LYNCH AND
ERIC HOLDER IN THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
I DON'T KNOW.
THAT'S JUST A SPECULATION.
>> SEEMS LIKE YOU HAVE TO KIND
OF FOCUS YOUR FIRE.
>> Laura: REALLY?
THEY ARE FACTS.
>> WHAT I WILL SAY IS I WOULD
OBSERVE TWO THINGS.
I AGREE WITH YOU AND I AGREE
WITH OUR DISCUSSION THERE.
I PREFER, I WOULD PREFER IF
PRESIDENT OBAMA AND ALL PREVIOUS
PRESIDENTS, YOU KNOW LET IT GO.
LET THE BATTLES BE FOUGHT NOT BY
THE OLD ADMINISTRATION.
LET THE NEW ADMINISTRATION --
EVEN IF YOU THINK THEY ARE
MAKING MISTAKES, I DON'T THINK
IT'S RIGHT FOR THE PRESIDENT TO
BE THE ONE OUT LEADING PERSONAL
ATTACKS.
YOU SAW WITH THE BUSH
ADMINISTRATION, GEORGE BUSH WENT
TO THE RANCH, AND DICK CHENEY
TOOK A DIFFERENT APPROACH.
HE WAS VERY CRITICAL GOING AFTER
THE ADMINISTRATION.
I FAVOR THE BUSH APPROACH.
I WISH OBAMA WERE NOT BEING AS
CRITICAL AS HE IS.
THAT SAID, I DON'T THINK IT'S AN
EXAGGERATION WHEN THE PRESIDENT
SAYS THERE ARE MORE PEOPLE BEING
INDICTED AND THERE HAVE BEEN
MORE SCANDALS UNDER THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION THAN THERE WERE
UNDER THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
>> Laura: I UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING, TECHNICALLY
THAT'S TRUE.
HOWEVER, WHAT HE'S INTENDING ALL
OF US TO TAKE AWAY FROM IT IS WE
HAD THIS ETHICAL GROUP.
THEY WERE ONLY IN THERE TO DO
GOOD STUFF.
WELL, I MEAN.
>> I WAS TRYING TO DO GOOD
STUFF.
>> Laura: I AM NOT SAYING YOU
WEREN'T.
WE LOVE YOU.
>> I STARTED FROM THE SPOT THAT
I AGREE WITH YOU.
I DON'T THINK THAT THE
PRESIDENT, THE FORMER PRESIDENT,
SHOULD BE SAYING THAT ABOUT THE
CURRENT PRESIDENT.
>> Laura: GO-AHEAD.
>> I WOULD SAY I DON'T THINK
THAT'S QUITE CORRECT.
ERIC HOLDER WAS THE FIRST
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO BE HELD IN
CONTEMPT OF CONGRESS.
LOIS LERNER PLED THE FIFTH
AMENDMENT THEN WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN WITH THE
OBAMA FBI, CIA, NSA, DOJ
OFFICIALS.
THE VERDICT IS NOT OUT ON BRUCE
OHR.
EIGHT TO TEN FBI OFFICIALS HAVE
BEEN RETIRED OR REASSIGNED OR
MAYBE FACING INDICTMENT.
JAMES COMEY, JOHN BRENNAN, JAMES
CLAPPER, IT'S NOT OVER.
WE ARE LOOKING AT A SITUATION
WHERE PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE
HIRED A FOREIGN NATIONAL TO FIND
DIRT ON HER OPPONENT IN THAT
DOSSIER WAS SEATED AMONG TOP
OFFICIALS IN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
>> Laura: WE DIDN'T HAVE A